good morning John I'll be Halloween and
now everybody finally gets to Steve I am
I'm Jane cub from the show Firefly and
if you don't know who that is
go watch Firefly hello yes come in
others Kaylee isn't she adorable
I'm out of town at a friend's wedding
and it's Halloween marvelous holiday in
which we carve gourds attempt to
frighten each other and ourselves
children full of candy and dress is sexy
watermelon seems to me that there is
nothing that Halloween cannot sexify and
so I would like to challenge the world
in general and nerdfighteria
specifically to create for me a sexy
marie curie costume i haven't found that
yet and i want to see it no Catherine's
Kaley and I'm Jane I know that they were
never together but I feel like it
probably would have been at least for
like a one-night stand or something at
some point in the series and so we're
just exploring that alternate future so
enough about our costumes additionally
as a Halloween special for you all I
went out to visit a company in my
hometown that makes tools specifically
for killing zombies small business the
lifeblood of America these guys are the
embodiment of the American dream and
also the embodiment of some other much
weirder dreams so just to be clear these
guys didn't start out as metalsmiths
they started out as martial artists and
so they loved to hit stuff with swords
and so they'll let you come to the shop
watch them work hang out in exchange for
payment and that payment comes in the
form of pumpkin pumpkins and other
things that you can slash with swords
and so I brought them some pumpkins and
I got to hang out with the guys from
zombie tools and it was pretty fun and I
made a little mini music video that I
would like to share with you now
[Music]
I'm not a kind of guy who really like
gets off on weaponry though of course I
am like festooned with holsters at the
moment none of them have anything in
them except this one has my eyeglasses
in it you know I kind of feel funny
about weaponry in general it's sort of
sort of intrinsically not awesome
because it's you know for hurting people
but these they're mostly for killing
zombies and pumpkins pumpkins of course
and to be honest bisecting a pumpkin
with the apakah tana was like pretty fun
thanks to dr. noise for letting me use
that song little soldier you can find
more of his stuff in the doobly-doo
thanks to the nerdfighter who gave me
this hat without which I could not have
been Jane for Halloween and thanks to
the guys of zombie tools for letting me
come hang out and hit stuff with swords
you see check out that website at zombie
tools Dutton if you're not in the market
for an edged weapon they also have a
pretty epic zombie apocalypse calendar
that you can check out if you haven't
had enough Halloween and you haven't had
enough this there is a zombie truth or
fail up at youtube.com slash truth or
fail I'll put a link to that around here
somewhere John I hope you're having an
excellent Halloween I'm excited about
you being done with signing and I'm even
more excited about The Fault in Our
Stars coming out and I'll see you on
Wednesday